January could also be called mocktail
month I just made that up you like it I
love the proof I approve 100 well the
Venetian has us covered also Louis
caputa lead bartender at Rosina cocktail
bar is here to show us how we can cut
the alcohol but keep the fun right so
the cocktail collective in the Venetian
all we do is promote fun it's all we
really care about whether you're going
to have alcohol or a non-alcohol drink I
got you because you still have great
music yeah talented bartenders
phenomenal venues Furniture is great
everything is great great people
so I'm ready to show you some of the
drinks from the cocktail collector let's
do it let's do it what are we making
okay so first this drink is the
eastbound cooler this is you could get
this at Dorsey and some of the main
ingredients are watermelon and ginger
all our juices are fresh we have really
uh hard-working barbacks during the day
that juice everything fresh so hats off
to them
this is over at the Electra this is the
Byron Bay the Byron Bay has fresh
passion fruit we have lime juice and
it's this yes you can I made that for
you no alcohol
whoa that is delicious I don't make bad
drinks that is so good now we were
talking about this really cool ice in
there so you can see it better here yep
explain that where'd you get that ice so
we have our Ice uh there's a few
companies in town that uh you get ice
from and the Venetian orders ice
regularly and we're just we get it and
we'll start using it that's cool you
guys if you want some cool ice there's
places where you can order in town okay
last but not least and so the drink that
I want to make for you today you can get
it Rosina and this is called an East
side tonic okay so fresh mint
we're going to do some cucumbers so you
know you could still make drinks that
are fresh and tasty whether they're
non-alcoholic or alcoholic okay and what
separates you know your cocktail
Collective mocktails from you know the
regular basic ones you can get anywhere
else well I'm going to say that the
cocktail collection continue to make the
cocktail Collective definitely you know
has bartenders that care we use fresh
ingredients I think the history of the
cocktail Collective really dictates that
you know with our expertise we really
know what we're doing yeah so
I think caring about the guest the most
really separates us from other places
well
okay then you add a little bit of
elderflower tonic water
very refreshing
give it a quick pour no I'm still over
here sipping on this one what am I going
to taste in this one so then what you do
is you freshen it up because you always
want the drinks to come out fresh okay
you add a little snazzy garnish which is
cucumber and mint sprig okay
metal straw so this should be a lot more
refreshing okay you know we have
something really refreshing too but we
have things that are sweet sour this
should be really refreshing
wow these are delicious let's not luck
we got you down see with the motto you
just need a great atmosphere and a great
bartender that's it I like it well
cheers cheers to dry January and
mocktail month now